[Music]
streaming if you haven't been familiar
with that I'll probably play a lot of
them these check us back I thought you
up here all right
I've hopefully a lot of mini-jack
because there's a lot of great custom
stories that I haven't had a chance to
place I'm I just wanted to do a big
[ __ ] amnesia marathon don't miss
saddling subscription your subconscious
mind is here to pull you from reality
keep you from failing failing falling
whatever victim to boring repetitive
that's whatever even they them and stuff
holla pity you're not the real mr. share
don't try it out already tired of man
it's just how alert you like my graphics
was that
oh it's teleporting API okay I'll shave
your ass [ __ ] what about you want to be
so scared camera actor I forgot to pray
for some guy I'm never [ __ ] heard of
them alright I'm probably never will
care about I'm sorry Joe Wilson I'm so
sorry Joe listen up
wait what the [ __ ] I saved you again
you must owe them jump scares them jump
scare no mr. Sherr is a [ __ ] hero i
county paid it charlie a mint
alright this [ __ ] place hey what is
this panel to read alright that's a clue
that's a clue right knee I guess it's
not time to go there maybe here
hello Peggy
yeah we're not pumped I mean a pump had
a pity how you been I'm here with the
piggy piggy number two Eunice we are in
the middle of something if you want to
excuse us all right I love you too long
all right let's just pick this up oh I
guess yep I picked up a game right let
me own trust this mother effer what's
going on over there he's just crying
I doubt fast yeah Jesus Christ
I'm breakdancing
it's on the other side all right you
coming yeah okay
all right if we picked up a key I don't
even know what the [ __ ] girls know
nothing go in there all right that's not
the door we were looking for these are
not the drowing drove out whatever I
don't know that joke meme whatever
all right panel one blue yeah Prague's
motherfuckas
yi yi I'm a snake yi yi
hey open please
there we go
[ __ ] look at this position it's like
yeah I'm dad for PETA fire whatever the
thing is I had the thing I have to go oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I guess I got trolled get them what the
[ __ ] I thought I could sneak by come on
alright at least he won't be here now
[ __ ] are we this is a map okay so you
are hair okay
but so I'm looking behind me yeah all
right yeah I guess there's one thing in
here so we might as well check it out
just check it out what oh here we go
first panel let's see here
no all right panel one below what what
all right fine that's what I'm doing
that's how I roll and the other one was
panel to read no further that wasn't it
them puzzles man all right you are here
girl afternoon telepathic naked guys
where was I other girl amongst ah he was
yeah aisle three green
what are you doing oh you can't see it
unless you go close or what's going on
ah god damn why did I waste my eye it's
okay I got finding that what the [ __ ]
the old truth okay whatever I think we
are all we need I mean got old panels
and we got hold it I don't get my
Frankie I don't get it but this is this
anyway I did all the stuff you wanted
where's the phone oh Jesus Christ
hey I know nothing that nothing Latin
and that learner light no not nothing
done
why not right now no lighting that out I
don't know
lighting it out and then I'll know I'm
an old man and he'll like no no no no no
no no no I don't even know like why we
have to do these things
let's check here just the whole for the
chemo spell him in there that's that's
what we're looking for
Agia t I don't get just yeah I quite
frankly don't maybe not again I could
get it if I I could and mr. Sharon stuff
well what's going I think I have all
this stuff
sledgehammer you're coming with me let's
play man this is badass I mean I could
fight off the brute probably not but you
know I just can't get over how he's
laying so sexy okay let's focus beating
panel one stop all right here it is
I think I hope yes I
all right this is another panel what is
this fine
oh this is panel three I get it I get it
now I can hey don't fight back I'm a
woman all right
oh is it this is panel three and green
go up back up
stop doc don't fight me fine
what
I don't get it it's okay bye
fine stay like that see if I care I
actually I do care
god damn it all right let's find the
other panels I suppose ash potent you'd
find a panel I know there's one here and
this is panel number two all right I am
good at puzzles all of a sudden okay all
right read up yes
all right and see if they fight back
they fight back you know this don't
worry sir
these guys look how much I have okay
good point actually I'm sorry yeah all
right
I thought you doing let's go here I
suppose I need to find ladder land near
three maybe they're marked on the map
okay fine I'll check the map
don't you want from a you didn't go here
though hey let's when the map is so I
guess that makes songs what else one day
I wonder and no laughs so I just go
right forward and then right all right I
got it
all right no way that was right all
right and forward and then he it should
be in he I depending on what we got damn
it got freakin damn it all right let's
do that again
let's do that again all right
let's go alright alright alright I got
it
I hope I don't get it i mean i of course
i got it i am stefano alright why i'm
peter by just crying
alright that's here no no as testing you
of course not again just testing if
you're know what you're doing this I
sure as hell don't maybe in here no not
he here probably I got I got it I got it
before you got it damn it it's locked
okay we have a kids cool yes yes I did
it Obama so I saw the puzzle alright I'm
coming with your coming with me mr.
Sherr all right Peter near gingers
finally I'm so happy look at me there's
me happy I'm so happy
okay stop I'm getting motion sick all
right what what are you kidding me I saw
them again and my son what what what
what piggy piggy piggy piggy I'm piggy
but you not [ __ ] smile hey I'm doing
something yay
all right we're doing seven eight your
own trap all right I'm sorry sorry jeez
all right I'll leave you alone but what
no what did I do wrong
I'm audible I'm out of all things gonna
be sad what I solved the puzzle now tell
me I know
this is panel number two let's double
check I suppose panel two Reds I see red
all right I hear clickety-clacking and
those are refusing to cooperate all
right fine all right good we check panel
number two let's check the other panels
just for fun
because it's so much fun checking panels
you know if I could do this in my spirit
Oh watch me I'm doing Emily it's prayer
time wow that's depressing
okay there's one here this is channel
number three girl let's check out which
tab is in green all right let's do your
for you sing to cooperate and you're
refusing to cooperate and I'm out of oil
and you're glowing pretty sweet there
good girl
all right it's fine light won't and in
this [ __ ]
I just had a lot of fun in the darkness
alone that sounds very nice and it
should work now I don't know what I did
differently but I'm of his magic she
missed I just jerked the levers and all
that all the sudden it was hey what is
this
alright I have created a potion that
will hopefully lead to peaceful Salaam
now we're back here the father tell me
what's going on I was just playing a
trick on you but I still have oh oh no
oh no you said ever since the bus just
to be a blame Jess Christ it does not
look alright
it's so [ __ ] that I don't know this
song we don't have this showing we
didn't saw I'm sorry I'm sure it's
really good I know those are fun cousin
story thanks cutie pie uh you're welcome
thanks Tyler I guess I hope so thanks to
the right guy anyway
right now do it shoes you ordered a nice
that was fun to play I hope you enjoyed
like afraid if you're dead I'm beginning
I get a lot of use of my initiatives but
I I don't get good rating so prove me
wrong I don't know
that's pretty much it I'll have a new
one tomorrow
[Music]
yeah there we go
are they kidding yeah I know